[Music]
joining me today is a New York Times
bestselling author a presidential fellow
at Chapman University the founder of
skeptic magazine and now a four-time
Rubin report guest Michael Shermer
welcome back is right my fourth time
here at times that's a record or without
it you are close you are you're
definitely in the top two or three no
cool all right depending on how this
goes do I get a pay bump yet no but
there's plenty of booze that's right
yeah that's right so alright there's a
ton I want to talk to you about you've
got a new book coming out I was saying
to you right before you started you're
the only guest that has two books all
right mark skeptic okay good well you
you were doing well we could bump we
could bump the skeptic and put heavens
on earth there because I hate to be the
life book guy that kicks the other
person off the out of the lifeboat we
will swap those two I thought a fun way
though to start this conversation with
you would be to tell a little story that
happened to us both when we spoke at
University of Arizona about two or three
months ago we were we were speaking
there with who were with that night we
were at Steve Simpson yes from the I
Rand Institute we're just able to talk
on free speech about an hour talk half
hour or so Q&A and in the middle I
jokingly said to the audience by a show
of hands are there any Nazis here it's
very and to our surprise someone raised
their hand or a woman raised her hand
and said that she was a Nazi and she
started to ask a question I said you
know what hang tight he'd respect our
free speech we're gonna do our thing but
then when we open this up to the Q&A
we're gonna throw the first question to
you so this person then proceeded to ask
a question can you paraphrase what the
question was basically oh well it was
something about she had encountered me
before it's some public event about the
Holocaust story and you know some
details about the gas chambers and you
know one of these kind of technical
arguments that they come up with that
are supposed to stump Holocaust
historians but that I've refuted before
and then she wanted to revisit
that so basically it was she was a
Holocaust denier and the beauty of what
happened why I wanted to start this
conversation with this antidote was she
asked you this question about the doors
at Auschwitz and why they didn't lock
and all of this I'm sorry was bad that's
right the doors of mad housing yeah
right yeah yeah and basically you gave
her a great answer of why the doors
unlock and they didn't want to scare
people with doors that lock at an
obviously very scary place and all this
stuff and it was it was a really nice
moment for free speech I thought she
actually respected our free speech we
then allowed her to have the question
you then answered her question now it
was pretty obvious to me that you didn't
change her mind at the end and that's oh
that's the first question I would ask
when you when you come by as someone
that debunks conspiracy theories all the
time and created skeptic magazine when
you come across these people that are so
sort of tightly held to their conspiracy
theories or the ideas that they can't
prove but they just believe them right
how often can you actually break them
you can actually I get letters all the
time I don't have it like a data set
from 25 years with 10,000 subjects or
anything like that but I get a ton of
letters just from people saying you know
I used to believe X and now I believe
why I changed my mind after reading your
book or you and Dawkins or Paris or
Hitchens or you know whatever this sort
of a list of people that we know and so
I do think this idea that you can't talk
somebody out of something that they
didn't you know you can't reason
somebody out of a belief they didn't
reason their way into I think it's not
true
even though probably they didn't reason
their way into the art the belief in the
first place once you have the belief in
place then you find reasons to believe
it and smart people are really good at
this educated will first people can pile
up the arguments and data in favor of
their belief and and disconfirm ignore
the disconfirming evidence you know the
confirmation bias so but you can do that
you can and so and now their Studies on
on this by cognitive psychologists like
you know if you're teaching critical
thinking and and the students believe
this how do you get them from there to
there whatever it is ESP or UFOs
conspiracies er or some political
economic idea so you can do this
by not standing at the blackboard
yammering away but by getting them to
debate and engage with each other like
okay so you're pro-choice okay you're
now gonna argue the pro-life position
against this person here who's gonna
take the opposite position what they
believe and that sort of forces them to
think well okay what are the arguments
in favor of this now I got a make up and
then this forces them to listen to the
other person and think about that and
then they can they really have a sense
of what's the best arguments because
they have to make them so really it's
just engaging in a process it's like
you're not gonna learn to play the
violin by reading a book about violins
or listening into a lecture about how
the violin works you got to just do it
in your years of doing this have you
learned anything about the mind of the
type of people that are prone to
conspiracy theories is there like a
certain set of ideas that they more
broadly subscribe to before it gets to
whatever the yeah yeah so there's kind
of a global cognitive style that
everything happens for a reason now for
religious people this is you know Jesus
or God is sort of directing things
everything from the parking spot you got
to the college you went into your spouse
that you met and and so forth the little
to the big questions for the
conspiracists it's the government it's a
little g-god government that's you know
pulling the strings and even if it's you
know if the Illuminati or the one-world
or whoever the Rockefellers the
Rothschilds it's still kind of a
government type that there's somebody up
there pulling the strings so that
everything that happens for a reason so
and we know that from surveys that
people that tick the box that that you
know JFK was assassinated by a
conspiracy are also more likely to tick
the box that Princess Diana was murdered
you know Elvis is still alive you know
that you know the aliens are being
hidden in area 51 you know so they they
go down the path they tend to accept
more and more ideas and we might call
that you know a gullibility tendency or
something like that but there's
something beneath that which is
everything has a reason for why it
happens and that they downplay the role
of chance and randomness so it's
interesting how you relate that to the
religious
because there's a desire really to
understand what's happening and yet
right the desire I think you would argue
that you then have to take a lot of
things that aren't true
for fat like there's sort of no ending
to it right that's right they never get
to the end of the conspiracy theory and
then it's exposed really it just sort of
takes you further and uh and the rest
like an x-files series it's like one
episode leads to the next and they keep
pulling the strings the thread and that
keeps unraveling forever so it's really
a self-fulfilling prophecy in a way
right if you can never be proven wrong
because that's right yes yes yeah so I
was just debating just online for the
UFO people about this new story about
the Pentagon had this program to study
UFOs now they call them unidentified
aerial phenomenon UAP sounds more
technical right and that is goofy but
but of course you know they're
interested in an unidentified aerial
something or other because it could be
the Russians or the Chinese or who knows
what you know so it's perfectly
reasonable to also then understand that
well the government's that you know they
lied to us yeah no kidding government's
do lie to their citizens right you know
but but a good counter to this is you
know the the WikiLeaks you know here
here we have you know millions of
documents that were secret that we
weren't supposed to see and now we see
them and there's nothing in there about
9/11 was an inside job the alien bodies
are being held at area 51 the UFO was
engineering technology was back
engineered and this is how we got the
Space Shuttle nothing nothing like that
so then this is a good example that
they've released yes that's right yeah
yeah well but presumably you know the
WikiLeaks guys weren't you know hiding
the good stuff and and releasing only
because they've released you know
millions of documents so this is an
example of the absence of evidence is is
evidence of absence
in terms of that argument usually that
doesn't that doesn't hold water but in
this case I think it does so where are
you just sort of personally are you
feeling good about the state of
skepticism at the moment or are you
feeling that fake news and the
authoritarian control on both sides
these
just that everything so up in the air
yeah I feel good about what it is that
you do and I know it seems like we're
not supposed to and they are of Trump
and all this stuff but really things
just keep grinding along and in a
positive fashion the counter to the fake
news and alternative facts are all the
new fact-checking sites like pull it
effect and Snopes has gotten huge now
and that's skeptic we're just we're
gonna launch a fact-checking site
because this is the kind of thing we
should be doing and and there's I don't
know there's half a dozen of those sites
that every political speech now given is
followed by really clickbait tweets on
here are the 27 facts that are wrong in
this speech oh my I want to see what
they are yeah so really that's the
market counter to that not censorship or
we need laws about fake news no we just
need people thank Jackie and then when
you're having problems with even that
that people go to those sites and then
even if you fact check it they still
don't believe the facts that they don't
like like we've really yes yeah that for
the ground sort may be but on the other
hand the moment like post modernists and
or even like behavioral economist say
that you know we're incapable of reason
yeah what are your arguments and reasons
for that statement then the moment they
open their mouth they've refuted them so
right because we still use arguments and
reason even if you're even if your
arguments are your data or fake or you
know questionable you're still trying to
make a good argument so that
enlightenment program of we use science
science and reason to make political
progress is still in place yeah well
that concept I think is really
interesting because you have all these
people right now who think either you
know the Armageddon is coming tomorrow
or everything everything's never been
worse I think we hear that over here
we've never hated each other more ababa
and I'm pretty sure it was the first
time I had you on the show and we were
talking about the moral arc which is
right over there that you were saying
that the arc of progress has bent so
that actually things are better but it
but it seems like we don't really stop
and smell the roses that's that seems
like a bigger problem to me at the
moment and if and when something does
get exposed as you know here's this evil
in society that now we're alerting to
like me to movement and
and some of the other ones that have
happened in the last year or so that
just exposes how far we've come and how
sensitized our moral compass is to
things that are really bad and that
we're gonna jump on it and not allow
this anymore so that if anything it's us
and like with the stuff we've talked
about with the student protests you know
complaining about Halloween costumes
okay this is actually a sign of progress
I mean no one worried about Halloween
costumes in 1950 okay the moral
Crusaders like Martin Luther King
weren't you know Oh what are the
Halloween costumes good they're worried
about you know the KKK costumes that are
real okay so that's how far we've come
when it can be so finely tuned that
we're gonna pick these little knits over
here does that also show you why the
level of hysteria maybe is ramped up so
much because the less stuff there is to
really fight about yeah there isn't some
stuff but the less stuff that really we
don't this isn't the 1950s KKK it's and
maybe a couple losers with a truck that
it could be that's why the people that
scream don't have to scream louder
because they sort of need it you know I
think so yeah
yeah and I you know the fact is they say
students at colleges like at Evergreen
they have their moral modules ramped up
to 11 like any of us do on a cause we
believe in it's just that from a bigger
picture when you look at well what are
you all ramped up about what why is your
moral module dialed to 11 over this
silly little thing here well they don't
know what it used to be like you know
half a century ago they weren't even
alive so they have the issues they're
concerned about but they have the same
moral modules everybody else is so what
do you make of the state of education in
general I mean everything we talked
about everything you've written all
these books about yeah it's based in
educating some people first yes yes it's
still the most important thing we can do
I don't think higher education is gonna
disappear I don't think brick-and-mortar
universities are gonna disappear I think
they'll just be more options
online options say you know all these
MOOC courses and and you know teaching
company courses and audiobooks and
podcasts and so on these are just more
avenues for dispersing information and
ideas and discussing them I think that's
just going to continue and along with
standard educational things now again I
mentioned earlier about you know the the
professor standing at the
blackboard yammering away for hours
while the students are on there now
they're just on social media not even
listening okay so that's what has to
change I think professors teachers need
to get more engaged I'm a professor I
know this is harder to do it's easy once
you've got the lectures written you got
the PowerPoint setup you just walk in
boom and off you're off and running 50
minutes later you're done and you're off
having your coffee okay
it takes more preparation to think about
okay I got how am I going to get these
students to engage in this subject in a
way that they'll actually get something
out of it and that takes more work so I
think you gave me an example already but
tell me a little bit about how you
prepare so you're teaching skepticism
101 yeah Edmund from everything I know
about Chapman who's the the Dean that
danielle east Rupa yeah is the president
is the president yeah so I heard him
speak a couple months ago in Alice at an
event and it was an absolutely wonderful
defense of free speech of seers of
enlightening values of what academia is
supposed to be that's right I wanted to
say hi to map an adventure that you've
been on my show a couple times but so it
seems like you guys are doing something
right over there is that fair they are
yes absolutely they they are not a
politically left or right University
they're just open to ideas the fact that
they have the you know statues of the
civil rights champions like Martin
Luther King but also economic freedom
champions like Hayek and and von Mises
you know they're on campus you know
others might think oh this is a right
wing you know libertarian nut job can't
no actually I had my students one
semester for their research project new
try to sample the faculty on their
political beliefs now I talked to
Danielle about this and he and the
administration are not allowed to do
this they can't ask professors what
their political persuasions are but the
students can just you know just sort of
email take my little survey and it was
pretty centrist there was still you know
a slight leaning toward the left you
know I don't know where you'd put it on
the scale but left-leaning and but but
by Berkeley or evergreen standards this
would be right wing all right you know
nutjob campus but really they're just
kind of centrist and I actually think
there's probably a little bit of a bias
that you and I have been subject to in
the sense that we focus on the
evergreens and in the Middlebury
incidences because they do stand out and
we forget all that you know so evergreen
has like 4,000 students right there was
maybe 200 involved in the whole Bret
Weinstein thing all right what were the
other 3,800 doing they were probably
holed up in their dorm rooms they don't
want to get involved they're not
interested they just want to study you
know I but I think but my fear with them
is that it's a little bit of
intellectual hostage-taking that yes you
might be right the the large bulk of
them may not care about this or may
think it's silly or whatever but I think
there's a huge percentage I don't know
what the percentage is that are just
afraid to speak you know every time I
speak in colleges that's what they asked
me in the Q&A s what can i I don't want
to get kicked out of college right at my
fraternity
I had my professor flunk me all that
that there is this feeling of that I
don't know that anyways I've never seen
numbers on that that would be a good
question hard to get the data itself
report data and people it's hard to get
people to be honest about that sort of
thing but I'm let's say it's 50/50 half
don't care have to care and keeping
their mouth shut
every semester I ask my students how
many of you self-censor because you're
afraid to say something like the
politically correct language or whatever
and you know the most of them raised
their hand yes they do some self
censoring so for sure that that happens
but I was encouraged by the Reed College
incident where you know the humanities
101 was protested its to white male you
know Shakespeare and Greeks and Romans
and then filing some black students you
know said get out I want to get my
education I'm paying $50,000 a year yeah
and it's like good alright so fighting
back what do you think it makes it the
audacity of an 18 year old to get up I
mean I watched that video people can
find it on YouTube I think the classroom
is about Greek the history of Greeks who
have given us over but every balance
that logic and reason that we have right
now yeah and talking about how it's
white supremacists and all the usual
nonsense but to me it was like those
kids who get up and do this it's not
like the level of self-importance Maury
so off the charts that you dare it's not
even what you're doing to yourself it's
what you're doing to all of these other
prime paid to go to school and you think
you're wiser right the professors and
administrators and all that is really
well we do have research on this from
Social Psychology for
Cades now that you only need a few
Confederate a few yet Confederates
people that will just go along with you
now the competitors not the right where
that's what experimenters put somebody
in there but but affiliate somebody that
will stand with you like in the Milgram
experiments if there's somebody else in
the room with you that says wait a
minute I don't think we should be
shocking this guy then the actual
subject will not go this far on the
shock things in same thing with the line
lengths Solomon Asch is famous one you
know here's three lines you know here's
one line and pick the one that matches
it and everybody in the room says it's
this this one over here it clearly
doesn't match it most of the subjects go
along with the group but if you have one
other in the room that picks the right
link line then almost everybody does
pick the right so you only need one or
two affiliate just somebody to stand
with you and it's just sort of common
knowledge that oh is like the emperor
has no clothes if somebody would just
say it right maybe two or three people
would say it that everybody else who
already knows what the truth is that
then they have the courage to say if
there's not punishment for it so
logistic regimes in communist regimes
have always kept a check on that by
punishing dissenters which is why free
speech is so important but but also
whistleblowing we have to protect
whistleblowers have to protect protect
and in a way you know like with virtue
signaling we need to signal to the
people that are willing to stand up you
get moral points for what you just did
yeah well I think that's why I've tried
to be part of this conversation at some
level but also talk to all of these
people so when this happened with Brett
Weinstein or Laura Kipnis or Lindsey
Shepherd or Jordan Peterson etc etc I
offered them that chair because I want
people to surface yes that's right as
Douglas Murray sent me when I asked him
you know people think you're so brave
you talk about all of this stuff and the
crumbling of the West yes yeah and I
said well what makes you so brave and he
said well you know something to the
effect of in his great British accent
you know the water the water is in so
cold when you actually get in and I
think that's what it is that we're going
to sort of imagine that if you start
saying what you think horrible things
are gonna happen but in most cases I
think they've don't yeah so I mean like
the Lindsey Shepherd you got yes you
know she's a complete nobody who's ever
heard of her but
now she's like the sensational star of
freedom and liberty and free speech and
and is anything with Jordan Peterson I
know he has a lot of enemies but boy
he's got a lot of followers my god yeah
it's just huge and so I think there's
more people on that side they they
haven't been as loud and the other side
has a bigger voice because you know
negativity always Trump's positivity you
know it's it's like Pete it's like I
talked about in the book you know people
hate to lose more than they like to win
no it's a it's a behavioral economics
loss aversion loss is hurt twice as much
as gains feel good you know our brains
are tuned to negative things for very
good reasons that you know evolution and
the life before the modern world was a
dangerous place there's a lot of things
that could take you out and very few
things that make life better so it's
better to focus on the negative things
that can take you out and then just sort
of accept the good days as they come but
you don't have to pay that much
attention to it so the you know the
negative tweets in social media they
always stand out which is why you just
kid don't read um yeah it's or not to
but so is this sort of the theory behind
I guess every local news broadcast in
the history of the world it's just you
know fire here murder here is yeah
that's their test to do that that's okay
yeah you know we just have to remind
ourselves that is not representative of
the way life is how can we change our
brains to think differently then because
I think a lot of people want that right
now I think there's there's an
exhaustion with the outrage I think
there's an exhaustion with hating each
other and all that that's why you know
what we're doing and this broader group
of people yes and I think that's why
it's working we just have to make our
voices louder and just remind people you
know there are lots of sources to go to
to show how long good luck just really
one in your green room of a site that
had the 99 best things that happened in
2017 that made it the best year in the
history of humanity there's like a long
title like the 99 oh my god it started
scanning that is like oh yeah I forgot
about that last February this really
cool thing effing moo-moo-moo-moo boomin
even I am a super optimist that I pay
attention to stuff I didn't know half
the things on his list like oh yeah Wow
okay so here we go yeah and people like
you and Pinker you
that really who you know track the the
which that site our world and data human
progress that org I think or calm human
progress you know and they just this is
all they do is track this stuff you know
poverty will be extinguished by 2030
maybe sooner you know the Gates
Foundation posts all this stuff that
work they're doing to eradicate disease
in Africa you know specific target which
is why you know I rail against utopia in
this book but instead of aiming for like
in a thousand years gonna have a perfect
world forget that just try to eradicate
this particular disease in the next ten
years in that country right there that's
it yeah alright we're gonna dive deep
into this book but let's just do a
little bit more before then you said
you're an optimist we're how does that
how does a skeptic become an optimist
well this may just be temperament I'm
just sort of a happy fellow and I I just
tend to see the world fairly
optimistically I'm not sure why that
could just be you know the behavior
genetic stuff half of our temperament is
heritable it's got it from my parents so
and I do tend to you know Steve Jobs had
that reality distortion field he talked
about you know no Steve we can't program
this in by next month yes we can and you
will you know these are not the drones
you're looking I will get it programmed
but yes I have a little bit of bad not
not to that extent that can be a little
dangerous you know like I'm going to
ignore the cancer and just you know no
there's some things you shouldn't ignore
but for the most part when I get up you
know it's like like everybody else is
like what am I gonna do today and I
don't feel that motivated and then I
just sort of get going and then and I
tend to perceive things that could be
negative in a positive way sometimes I
have to sort of force myself I do follow
people on Twitter for example that are
pretty positive like Pinker or like
jackal will Nick you know he's he's you
know he tweets every morning his workout
I've started you see his watch 4:30
Oh am yeah yeah alright so then I think
okay you know what I can do this come on
and I learned tended to start reality a
little bit we do know from research on
entrepreneurs and other people that it's
good to be a little on the optimistic
side versus pessimistic side now you
don't want to have the over optimism
bias see the entrepreneurs I think I can
succeed no matter what they just keep
plowing money and
failed business you know that's that's
not good and of course we only hear
about the Steve Jobs of the world you
know the here's the model drop out of
college I move back to your parents
house and start a start-up in the garage
and you'll be a billionaire right I just
leave there's a lot of people that did
that the 70s and no one writes
biographies of n cuz we went out of
business
pissed parents with old yeah so you know
there's too much of that but but too
much too much negativity makes you feel
so it's called learned helplessness like
there's nothing I could do I mean you
know we got Trump and we got the economy
in North Korea Syria oh it's just it's
all lost what's the point I can't do
anything I'm just one person
and then you just kind of sink you know
like there's nothing to do that's not
good either
so as an optimist and a skeptic
regardless of how much of this was just
built in in your DNA how much do you
think is sort of the right amount of
news to take you know and it's all
sometimes people say well Dave why don't
you do a daily show right we could do
this five days a week yeah am i feeling
generally beyond that I don't even know
that the economic economic part makes
sense to us is that I think there's a
limit to how much people should be
talking about I do to politics all the
time that you could have a Twitter feed
screen right here and sit here 24/7 it
would never end it really sounds like my
worst night look what happened now yeah
yeah I think that's too much I do
consider I'm a consumer of content I do
tend to prefer the kind of long-form
essays you know the old New Yorker
Atlantic styles and I still read those
but now there's a lot of good sites like
this a on a eo-n site quill let in Louis
Roulet in Australia they have these
three three to five thousand word essays
they're great
that's the kind of content I like I do
sometimes slip over into just the daily
stuff and I find if I don't stop you
know I'm just I'm sliding down and my
optimism is like oh god what can I do
it's just that Shermer stop just get off
close it close the laptop you're pretty
good about it though because I don't see
you fighting with that many people
online although every now and again I've
seen you get into something with another
academic somewhere and I've opened the
door I can't even remember the woman's
name it's not even that important unless
you want to specifically talk about it
but you got into something with some
woman about post-modernism
and I said hey let's let's talk about
alone you know and then she's really
said saying that it's basically that
you're a sexist and I'm impartial and
the usual yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah well
you know I'm 63 right so I'm not you
know super engaged because I'm slightly
older although I did get into the social
media enough to like I can see this is
kind of where the the conversation is
shifting you know from books and you
know public lectures to online content
and I like it but I'm not obsessed with
about it you know people that are maybe
in their 20s and that maybe they just
can't you hear about this you know
addicted to social media addicted to
your phone it's like really but I can
see I could see how it happens you get
the little dopamine hit every time you
you know you scroll through and you see
your name on there and do you think that
amount of information at our fingertips
also feeds into why people believe in
conspiracy theories well it's just more
available yeah yeah for sure yeah yeah
so like maybe 20 years ago 25 years ago
it would have been harder for the 9/11
truthers to get it told whatever the
equivalent of that would have been the
Watergate inside job or whatever because
they didn't have a platform that
everyone's a publisher now and you can
just have your own web page that looks
like a magazine or whatever and that
they would've been harder to find
they're available and you could find
stuff but you know it's more like ersatz
publishing or you put pamphlets and a
leaflets on car windshields or you you
know you go to lectures and say stuff
now it's just it's too easily available
but on the other hand so are the counter
pages that can debunk them yeah that
part's good so I want to talk a little
bit about your politics specifically
because you took the political compass
test a couple months ago well yeah and
you posted your results online and then
I took it maybe a day or two after we
were pretty damn close yeah yeah all
right that's good because I like same to
me okay and it basically we both came
out sort of center-right yeah so as you
know I've tried for a long time to
reform the left and I think this has led
left me as a liberal to be right and the
odd ways that things change over time
what do you even consider yourself at
this point I know you kind of said you
were a libertarian the first time I had
yes yes well well I bought your t-shirt
yeah
classical liberal classical liberal I
think maybe is the right phrase now the
libertarian label has gotten a lot of
baggage over the years it's collected a
lot of stuff from people on the fringes
you know so you don't believe in any
government no no no no and that's not
what I believe or or you know you're
like Rand Paul or Ron Paul or your EIN
Rand or you know they pluck these people
out and it's a cognitive shortcut a
heuristic in which I don't have to
actually talk to you about anything I
already know what you think so I don't
like that you know it's like well okay
don't ask me my what my political
affiliation is asked me my position on
abortion gun control death penalty and
so on and I'll tell you what I think why
I think it and then we can go from there
yeah you know but of course who has time
to do all that you know so we like the
labels yeah but let's do one of those
because I had been Shapiro on my side
yeah and you know we had a really I
think interesting honest sort of painful
at some level discussion about abortion
it's one of the most you know you know
difficult topics to talk about we never
in mainstream media see it discussed
honestly really that I see anyway and
basically my argument was that I'm
pro-choice but at basically twenty weeks
where they've been proven that at that
point the fetus can feel pain yeah then
at that point I think you probably could
say alright you can't have an abortion
but then that leads to all sorts of
other questions which is you know they'd
have to have a responsibility which I
don't like that right anyway Ben is
Benny's pro-life you you sent me a very
brief email with your thoughts on this
so yeah well I just yeah I was watching
it live which is it is great and so I
just sent that it was an article about
from a on actually about the history of
infanticide in our species you know a
lot but lots of species do this and
evolutionary biologists have studied
this for a century why would in a
Darwinian model why would a parent kill
an offspring that's their DNA well it
depends on the calculation of resources
available for how many you can bring to
reproductive age that is RS reproductive
success of a species depends is defined
by how much of your genes get into the
future genome of the species going
forward so if you are
selected species you have like salmon
you have you know ten million eggs and
you know a hundred of them make it to
the top of the stream and and they're
the ones that succeed if you're a
elephant or a primate you have two or
three and you put all of your resources
into those and so these are different
reproductive strategies and in our
species what's happened over all the way
up until really well into the 20th
century until the introduction of birth
control women just kill their babies
after they were born and it sounds cruel
but you know it's just a basic triage
decision to make I can't feed anymore
kids this you know when you live in
really anytime before the 20th century
it was pretty impoverished compared to
today's standards which is what we're
used to you just can't have that many
kids they're just gonna starve to death
or whatever and you know in lots of
societies anthropologist tell us you
know like these Inuits you know they
just leave the kid out there and if he
survives them for two days then we'll
bring him in and make them a part of our
family if not out you know Spartans did
the salaat societies did not because
they were immoral
you know they presumably they feel grief
about it but they just can't do it so
one argument among men well is there a
moral argument there though is it not
that they're not immoral you know well
there's something yeah this is a hard
question okay so I'm making the argument
that practically speaking if you
restrict women's ability to control
their family size they're gonna do it
anyway say okay you can't have an
abortion well just we're just gonna get
more trash camp babies more babies the
infant's left in the park now that's not
that's not a pure moral argument Ben
would say something like oh so you're
saying murder is fine before or after
birth no no I'm just telling you
historically this is what happens now
the ideal solution would be more
prosperity for women more control over
their reproductive choices and more
control over their family size and so on
access to abortion if you need it
but we do know from studies that
abortion rates go down when women have
you know more political power or
economic freedom and especially access
to birth control technologies and so
religion has traditionally restricted
those and that leads to more abortions
or in other cases more infanticide so
that's one thing like
I'm at it that's not it's really more of
a practical historical angle than a that
a purely moral one right so that's you
really just give me the realist yes it's
a realist yeah
now morally okay so like with these
difficult questions we have competing
moral dilemmas or competing moral
positions and and and they're going to
conflict with one another so you have
the rights of the fetus the rights of
the woman okay so there's not one right
answer so if you say well you should be
a utilitarian or you should be a Content
you know this will tell you what you
should do but but those aren't
necessarily absolutely right across the
board no one could be a pure utilitarian
or a pure Con Thien or Aristotelian
virtue ethics none of them work across
the board you can always find some
exception which is why we still have
these elaborate ethical debates because
it's not solvable you know so you have
the the the you know the state should
have some say over whether citizens
murder each other or not and they should
be able to implement punishments that
are appropriate so death penalty yeah
but there's all these other sites so you
have these conflicting so how do we
resolve it debate votes laws that get
changed legislation that changes and I
it's hard because there's not one
clearly right answer so I suspect that
you thought my argument was actually
pretty decent then right like it's been
yeah absolutely of course hundred
percent I'm a pro-choice
I forget exactly the way you said it
barely just but that basically at twenty
weeks
that's because then it gets you're right
it gets caught in now okay well if you
believe it's a life it's a life at
eighteen weeks and at twenty weeks so
we're we you know drawing these lines
all the time you have to draw the line
somewhere frozen embryos you know
there's millions of them now yeah why
are they not life on bends you know we
have it's at the moment there's
fertilization that's a life okay that's
true that's it's well it's a potential
human life now there's the question of
personhood slightly different because a
person has legal rights under the
Constitution of the particular country
and it's a slightly different question
than a biological question but either
way once by Ben's argument once the
fertilization that happens that's a
human life okay yeah it's potential
human life so killing the embryos
is also wrong I don't know what he'd say
about that actually haven't heard his
position but I'd say it's a continuum
and the problem the difference between
the law and science is that science
deals in Continuum's and gray areas and
shades and nuance the law by definition
has to just say okay this is the law we
draw the line you know on this day that
this month that's it
no no abortions after that are legal and
I'm okay with that
it's you know life is messy we have to
draw the line somewhere yeah all right
so one more thing before we get to the
book so I think one of the best things
that I did or that I was part of last
year was the debate that we had here
with you and dennis prager about not in
morality right and obviously you took
the position that you do not need God or
a higher power
yeah moral Dennis took the opposite
position so two questions on this so
first when I let when we finish that I
sort of my my brain basically and most
of my being basically agrees with your
argument that I don't think my morality
purely comes from believing in God or
that most people's you know that you can
figure out a way to be moral the
interesting part of the conversation
came down to this Microverse macro you
know argument where basically Dennis was
saying to you well well you Michael on
the micro level you as an individual can
be very moral and I have no doubt that
you're a very moral person I'm basically
paraphrasing him but that at a societal
level you know somehow the the man-made
morals that you prescribe to can't tie a
society together in the long term so
that we need these judeo-christian
values which then allow the
Enlightenment to happen to then have
great moral or a society
I suspect you don't agree with that we
got into it a little bit but I just
wanted to kick it to you without someone
else yes well hitch still dealt with
this in his book God is not great and he
even cites Prager he said I was on
pregger show once and he guessed this
question you know of course you
personally could be moral but you know
as a society wouldn't you rather walk
down the street at 3:00 in the morning
in a dark alley in a society that was
you know more religious than less
religious and he promptly rattled off
cities he had walked around at 3:00 in
the morning after drinking
they were very religious he was not at
all feeling comfortable or safe yeah and
any atom by name and you know a year and
so on it's like yes okay that's that's
right yeah you know mminton history I
mean most judeo-christian countries
centuries ago we're not safe places
where you could be burned as a heretic
if you have the wrong beliefs about the
king or whatever it doesn't matter what
your religious beliefs are these were
your fellow Christians killing you and
all the way up to World War one
you know Christian Germans killing
French Christians
did I say that right yes anyway so
they're correct or detailing yeah so now
but but even so that that argument is
really more of a pragmatic kind of
utilitarian argument that whether or not
there's a God or religion is true or not
believing in it
this is what Dan Dennett calls belief in
belief you know I don't believe but I
think people need to believe there are
some people that make that a lot of
atheist make that argument
hmm it's sort of a condescending way of
looking at your fellow citizens you know
right I don't need it I can be moral but
these morons know they got a head the
little policeman in the head are they
going to kill each other and in a way
the founding fathers sort of Jefferson
these people talked about that you know
more in a deistic way you know if we're
gonna have a kind of self organized self
policing society we can't get the state
out there to those western states which
was like Ohio at the time you know be
good if people believe in moral values
so they really believed in an education
and moral moral education as well and I
I think that's true but what's happened
is is that we've inculcated those
beliefs into our own beliefs without
meet the need of religion anymore
without the need of a pie in the sky
watching us because we're kind of
watching each other and so I think to go
one more step for Dennis he needs to say
that it actually needs to be a
supernatural implementation of a moral
sense into human the into human
cognition and I think that that is what
he believes God gave us our morals and
of course I had counters on that which
we talked about but but ultimately he
still needs that supernatural dropping
in because we can show that societies
can learn to be better and moral just
with secular law and order
yeah I like that you brought the
founders into it because as I say all
the time I you know I go to DC every
couple months probably at this point I
go to all of the monuments and all that
and when you read these things
especially Jefferson it's like this guy
was talking about church and state and
separation the necessity for church and
state to be separate well at the same
time was sort of was basically
acknowledging some sort of higher power
how much he believed in it is I think a
little unclear yeah but that then led to
all of the values that freed us so yeah
and as long ago enough that you know
we're used to talking in language that
doesn't include God talk at that time
you know that they were there were no
virtually no atheists no one was talking
about you know it's okay not to believe
in God I mean there was a famous story
about human to somebody's dinner at the
Enlightenment time you know you have
like Adam Smith and all these famous now
famous people and you know Hume says
well I don't know any atheist and it's
like you have a room full of him here
it's like oh my god yeah and now you and
I well course we live in LA and
California is a little more little yeah
so yeah that's not a big deal but I
think more and more it's becoming more
acceptable and their forward morals come
from well you know we talk about the
secular values enshrined in the
Constitution and the you know the law
and order of our society Western society
expanded Europe and so on and all of a
sudden you had in on the fastest-growing
group or the nuns the non-religious
people okay there's gonna be a third
maybe a half of the world in a few
decades maybe where are they gonna get
their morals well we know where they're
gonna get them where we get them from do
you think you can live a full life while
still splitting the difference on these
two positions because I think a lot of
people are like that and I think
sometimes I even fall into that where I
can you know and I see it around so many
people that are really smart that made
compelling arguments and I can
understand their lines of thinking and I
think that sometimes I can go to
different to those different places in
different ways yeah you can live like a
full complete life without ever fully
getting to an answer that that satisfy
you know that I think so I mean like
everybody else I would prefer to have
definitive answers I have to often have
to remind myself it's
what I always say it's okay not to know
but I'm not always comfortable with it
that'd be nice to know but really by
temperament again I think I think I'm
just of that scientific mindset of it's
okay to just have this question and the
more I study morals particularly when I
was writing the moral arc and now I'm
getting ready to teach this honors
course at Chapman on morality and ethics
and evolution you know so I'm rereading
all these you know debates about
abortion capital punishment we have a
textbook we're using that you know
here's the best argument for abortion
here's the best argument against
abortion and so on and it's like okay
yeah these are really good arguments on
both sides and you know it's like these
these these ethical ethics and moral
seminars you know where the professor's
driving you down the like it's like a
Peter Singer kind of thing you know like
is it okay to sacrifice children you
know the that are mentally [ __ ] like
what but when you actually listen to the
arguments okay it's not clear at all
which is the right moral position here
and and some reason I was just writing
about utilitarianism you know because
that this is a popular idea now it's
like wait wait wait there's some really
big flaws with you well then what we
like Conti in you know the categorical
imperative at has flaws what about
Aristotle's you know virtue ethics no
that has flat you know they all have
flaws yeah
all's I can think of is it's something
like this that the analogy I used in a
paper I wrote my moral manifesto that
when Kepler discovered that planets that
travel in ellipses and not circles you
know he could never no one could have
discovered something else if they're
doing their sums right and they they're
actually making accurate measurements
because that's what orbits actually
travel in I think human societies are
just many degrees of freedom more
complicated and that we're not going to
discover the answer to these moral
dilemmas but but but it's not like
post-modernism there is no moral truth
yeah maybe there's six you know that the
planets you have these six variations of
planetary orbit so humans you know have
like utilitarianism Conti and ethics and
so I think we've kind of figured out you
know a few basic principles like you
have to consider the other person's
position you know john Rawls's veil of
ignorance like
when you Dave room and are gonna write a
law you have to do it as if you might be
you know a black woman okay all right in
that case I'm not gonna write it to
favor white males you know in fact I
better write it so that everybody gets
treated equally under this law I'm about
to write okay that that's super basic
but it really works yeah in terms of
fairness to by just asking somebody else
how would you feel if this law were
passed and you were the one affected but
they'll tell you right so that principle
that we have to think about that when
we're legislating you know that's one of
those again so there's maybe in the last
a couple thousand years maybe half a
dozen these kind of moral positions and
you can see how they've sorted
themselves out and they're not many new
ones that come up you know try this try
that and they you know they either take
holder they don't because they work in
terms of like improving humanity a
little bit well now I know why I'm so
close to you on the political scale
because I love that answer and that's
the spirit that I try to bring to the
show every week I would love to say I'm
pro-choice and those guys are absolutely
hundred-percent wrong like Ben Shapiro I
know why he's wrong no actually I don't
I I think I can out argue him just
slightly but at some point here's my
arguments they're good here's his
arguments they're also pretty good all
right so we just decide
[Music]
you
[Music]